foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
when I was 23
I had just graduated from the University
of Hawaii with big hopes and dreams
started a career that would take me
Halfway Around the World
and I was in love
I was 14 years ago
and then everything seemed to fall apart
all at once
I was in the middle of a work shift at a
store in Honolulu when I picked up the
phone and heard my mom's voice on the
other end
and what she said brought my world to a
halt
my grandfather who is only 65 had
unexpectedly been given just two months
to live
[Music]
for the first eight years of my life
before my mom met and married my stepdad
my grandfather was the only father I
knew
it was hard to imagine a world without
him in it
in that moment over 4 000 miles of ocean
and land stretched between us
and
there I was
folding clothes when he had only two
months left to live
time seemed to both stop and speed up in
that moment
and everything else along with it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
I asked my manager for a transfer to the
mainland and soon I had left everything
and everyone I knew for a place that was
completely foreign to me
Kentucky
but I wound up quitting so I could
travel to see my grandfather another
family who lived further south
and then I just kept on traveling for
months actually
pretty much until I ran out of money
at which point I went back to work for
the same company
at a shopping mall in Florence Kentucky
as the months went by I began to feel
stuck
I didn't have many friends in Kentucky
or direction or motivation
I didn't want to go out to the bars or
meet anyone new or move up at work
I just wanted to stay untethered
unattached uninvested in this place that
just didn't feel like home
so instead I would sit in my room
peppered with empty photo frames and
unopened boxes and watched the sunset
from my window
overlooking the street below
[Music]
the more beautiful The View it's like
the more unhappy I felt
and that might sound strange but
I just wanted so badly to be out there
experiencing it away from the city just
someplace Wild
[Music]
I miss my old life in Hawaii so much but
for some reason I felt like that life
was no longer Within Reach and that
maybe this was just My New Reality
and all the rest was just a dream
[Music]
it doesn't take long to lose sight of
your dreams
to trade curiosity for routine
which is exactly where I found myself
Frozen somewhere between life imagined
and the life I knew
when my brother gave me a book
he said this is you you should read it
that book was Into the Wild by John
krakar
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
some say that Chris McCandless story is
dangerous
careless misguided
and maybe it is a lot of stories are
but even for those who have adhered to a
life of caution and responsibility
the outcome is still the same
none of us make it out alive
the question I wonder is did you live
and if given the choice would you do it
all over again
ready three two one go
oh
I haven't jumped on a moving train or
burned piles of cash or abandoned my car
in the Mojave Desert to wander around on
foot
I haven't crossed solo into Mexico on a
river raft or journeyed alone through
the Alaskan wilderness
when my brother said this is you
I sometimes wonder if he meant you would
do this wouldn't you
what
but more than that I think you recognize
the side of me I didn't yet understand
the side of me that felt a kind of
restless discomfort and persistent
desire to live outside the lines
to make sense of things in my own way
through experience exploration and
Escape
maybe he guessed that one day it might
break me if I kept it all inside
and who knows maybe he would have been
right
there's a passage from the book that
really stuck with me it's this scene
where Chris catches a ride from a local
man named Ron back to his camp
Ron asks how old he is and Chris says
23.
23 years old says Ron don't you think
you ought to get an education and a job
and make something of this life
I've been asked a hundred variations of
this same question throughout my life
and even more so since choosing my own
path
whatever the words the implication is
often the same
who Do You Think You Are
in other words who are you to sidestep
expectation while the rest of us
contribute
[Music]
I sunk a lot of energy into trying to
safeguard myself from these sort of
questions
I worked hard for good grades I put
myself through college I even subscribed
to the corporate life
partly for myself
but also because I thought that's what
life expected of me but it didn't take
long to realize the expectations didn't
end there because once you have the
degree and the job and the car you're
expected to have the marriage and the
house and then the kids and on and on it
goes
until one day you pause long enough to
ask yourself
is any of this actually what I want
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
was this
Mr friends
I think careers are a 20th century
invention and I don't want one
you don't need to worry about me
I have a college education I'm not
destitute
I'm living like this by choice
I didn't know that kind of response was
even an option at 23.
everyone I knew was following the script
myself included
and it's not as if I abandoned that
script right away
the shifts were subtle and there were
plenty of detours along the way
[Music]
but over time those words inspired me to
find my own path Into the Wild
[Music]
onto the road
and to build a life I love
[Applause]
one step at a time
it's hard to say where I would be now
without that book
it prompted a massive shift in my
everything
in the best possible way
one thing is for sure though
I probably wouldn't be 37 single living
in a van down by the river
and man wouldn't that be sad
[Music]
thank you for being here
and I will see you all in the next one
you're biting my foot bro I should have
[ __ ] unbuckled this first I need a
mosquito soup
it's so bad right here
thank you